when i first was elected vice president
with president
obama the military sat us down
to let us know what the greatest threats
facing america were the greatest
physical threats
this is not a joke you know what the
joint chiefs told us the greatest threat
facing america was
global warming climate change is a
threat but the president is looking at
it at a much broader angle
than i am i'm looking at it from a
strictly military standpoint
and from a strictly military standpoint
i'm putting china russia up there
well the chairman of the joint chiefs uh
mark milley feeling the need perhaps to
qualify or clarify the president's
statement on
wednesday as you heard he delivered in
england
the chairman of the joint chiefs went on
to say the number one military threat as
we go forward
is china but he considers russia a major
competitor
this as obviously the president
continues his european trip
let's bring in our panel ben dominic
publisher of the federalist katie
pavlich
news editor townhall.com and harold ford
jr former tennessee congressman
ceo of empowerment inclusion capital ben
your thoughts about that
well obviously i'd dispute president
biden's notion
regarding climate change but i'm very
curious to see
a number of things emerging from this g7
summit
including of course this meeting with
vladimir putin
which unfortunately i think is set up to
be really a coup
for putin in so many different respects
he's already got the nordstream pipeline
he's not going to have anything changed
in belarus ukraine is going to continue
in terms of a simmer you're going to
continue to have russian
actors whether government backed or not
extract
ransomware from from companies around
the world
and i think that you really are going to
see you know in a continued crackdown
on any kind of domestic pushback against
putin's regime
especially from alexei navalny this is
really going to be a situation where
you know after all of this talk of the
trump administration being
soft on russia you know the the outcome
when it comes to the biden
administration is almost certainly going
to be
you know some angry language or or some
some very stern talking to
from the president i don't really expect
anything to come out of it that's going
to encourage any of us who believe
that america ought to be pushing back
stronger against russian influence we've
talked a lot about
china and russia a little bit about iran
and the threats iran poses that came up
in this hearing today on capitol hill as
well
iran now docking and
doing business with venezuela take a
listen
allowing this ship to dock seems
significant to me
on many different levels it would be the
first time that iranian vessels
have made such a transit and the
precedent of allowing
iran to provide weapons to the region
causes me grave concern i am absolutely
concerned
about the proliferation of uh of uh
weapons uh any type of weapons uh
in in our neighborhood
defense secretary there katie
well this move by the iranians uh to get
even closer to the united states
and to build their alliance with
venezuela and trans use venezuela as a
transfer point for
weapons into south america certainly
isn't a gesture of goodwill while the
byte administration is still negotiating
and trying to get down to the wire on
some kind of
agreement to get back into the iranian
nuclear deal
the the obama administration always made
the argument that if we got back into
the deal that iran would improve their
behavior
on a number of different fronts we saw
that didn't happen in fact iran got more
aggressive once they
were in the nuclear agreement we're now
seeing that the more the obama
administration
negotiates that with them the more
aggressive they've become whether that's
sending ships to venezuela for a weapons
transfer or whether that's
funding hamas to wage a war against
israel
through hamas whether it's funding other
proxies in the region like the houthis
against saudi arabia
and so this concept of offering the
iranians a nuclear agreement and hoping
that in return
they will somehow change their behavior
we've seen the opposite of that happen
and it's happening
as we speak while they're trying to
negotiate some kind of agreement you
know herald
critics of the president have said that
uh iran china russia
see softness so they are acting in
various different ways to challenge that
at the same time on this trip the
president has had a success in the
world's eyes at least
this vaccination effort and 500 million
vaccines that was matched just before
the show started of another 500 million
from the g7 uh take a listen to the
president
america will be the arsenal of vaccines
in our fight against global 19.
just as america was the arsenal
democracy during world war ii
our vaccine donations don't include
pressure for favors or potential consent
concessions we're doing this to save
lives
to end this pandemic that's it period we
have the lowest
number of daily deaths since the first
day of this pandemic
our economy is rebounding our
vaccination program has already saved
tens of thousands of lives obviously the
white house is touting that as a global
effort
led by the u.s harold
look that's an example of thanks for
having me on uh it's an example of our
soft power
uh this president uh was a direct attack
also i think at china a direct line of
attack at china's he said we're not
looking for concessions
or favors from uh from those nations
that we seek to help
you know i i have a little different
opinion i found i found some of the
analysis interesting
with some of the other panelists but my
perspective is slightly different i
think this effort to build
to strengthen our multilateral approach
we should say strengthen relationships
with allies build even stronger ones
with
countries we're seeking to have a better
relationship with as we enter
the the mid innings of this cold war
with china i think is a very smart thing
the world is a messy place it's a
dangerous place it always
it always has been i'm relieved a bit by
the experience this president brings and
i hope that
he and secretary blinken and secretary
austin won't be afraid to pull and use
every lever and you have to be
encouraged to hear and watch them use
the soft power lever
as as much as they are without question
the dominant organizing theme for our
foreign policy over the next five 10
15 years my kids years in middle school
and high school and college will be how
we compete and beat china that's what i
heard from the
from our military leaders today in
congress and that's what i continue to
hear
from president biden and his team as
well we should point out there was also
an attack in baghdad on the state
department compound at the airport
just last night with a drone on there
looking for the culprits there
so it's a dangerous world to your point
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else